30 party is dragging the BBC through the
mud and it's unacceptable I think the
British public will be very angry this
is another example of this government's
incompetence Boris Johnson should never
have appointed Mrs sharp in the first
place and Richard Rishi soon act should
have shown some leadership by sacking
him
what do you think should be the process
for choosing the chairman of the BBC
then
I prefer an independent process and I
absolutely believe there should be a
hearing to check the appointment by the
cross party Select Committee in the
House of Commons for culture medium
sport that's the only way to forward so
people can have confidence just allowing
it to be the Prime Minister say so just
won't work anymore
and I just want to ask everyone who do
you blame for this having got to this
state
was it the the appointments process was
it Boris Johnson who do you think is a
response well Boris Johnson and the
conservatives must take the blame for
this uh Bryce Johnson appointed him and
Rishi sunak didn't get around and show
any leadership when he could have sacked
uh Mr Sharp when it was really clear
that this wasn't appropriate
um so I welcome this I call the little
Democrats called for Mr Sharp to resign
but really the conservatives are the
ones who should but she frankly
apologize to the British people
now Richard Sharp did convey some of
what he'd done to Simon case
what do you think of his position is it
under question well I think it's the
conservative ministers who've got to
answer they shouldn't hide behind anyone
else the conservatives keep dragging the
BBC through the mud that is not
acceptable people will be very cross
about that and I think Rishi sunak has
to apologize for his failure to sack Mr
Sharp